bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
sur notre antenne l'examen d'une
proposition de loi qui vise à moderniser
le congé maternité à mes côtés pour en
parler
claire-lise campion sénatrice socialiste
de l'essonne et auteurs de cette
proposition de loi
bonjour alors pourquoi vouloir
moderniser le congé maternité en france
alors qu'il est déjà d'une durée de 16
semaines ce qui place la france dans une
situation assez confortable par rapport
à d'autres pays dans une situation qui
est dans la moyenne à peine pas une
situation particulièrement confortable
il ya d'autres pays européens voisins
comme le portugal comme l'italie comme
le royaume uni et l'irlande qui ont
davantage de semaine donc l'idée c'est
de partir d'un constat le constat c'est
qu'il est difficile malgré toute la
volonté des pouvoirs publics de
concilier la vie professionnelle et la
vie familiale et notamment au moment
d'une grossesse et d'une maternité qui
annonce l'arrivée d'un nouveau né donc
l'idée a été aussi de prendre en compte
ce qui est la réalité aujourd'hui nous
avons seize semaines de congé de
maternité mais ce que nous constatons
c'est que plus de 70% des femmes au jour
d'aujourd'hui en france prennent des
semaines supplémentaires après avis
médical et il est jugé par les jets
pathologique congé pathologique souvent
deux semaines de congés supplémentaires
qui amène à 18 semaines et qui sont
jugés comme nécessaire pour améliorer
je dirais la période dans laquelle la
femme se trouve au niveau de sa santé
bien sûr et son équilibre personnel
psychologie
et physique après et au moment de
l'arrivée du petit donc ça aussi c'est
une réalité à prendre en compte
on est pour 70% des femmes françaises
plutôt à 18 semaines
la proposition est de partir également
de ce qui a été discuté sur le plan
européen sur une proposition de
résolution de la commission et du débat
qui a été menée par le parlement
européen au début de l'année 2010 les
collègues députés européens étant allé
jusqu'à proposer 20 semaines et une
indemnisation à 100% du salaire ce que
j'ai donc repris sur le plan national
ici au sénat et qui est discuté cet
après midi comment était perçue cette
proposition de loi par la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat la commission
des affaires sociales a été très
intéressé comme très souvent ou presque
à chaque fois que nous avons des débats
touchent la société
française qui touche à la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyens les
débats sont passionnants ils n'étaient
pas l'ont été ils ont été compris
passionné et ça c'est une bonne chose
j'ai reçu le soutien de collègues
sénateurs alors j'ai reçu le coup le
soutien des collègues des sénateurs de
l'ensemble des parties de des groupes de
gauche
j'ai aussi reçu le soutien partiel si je
peux m'exprimer ainsi à travers un
amendement qui ce matin a été discuté en
commission de la part du groupe
centriste amendement qui j'irai propose
les 18 semaines alors que je le répète
nous sommes assez aisé que je propose
donc j'ai émis ce matin un avis de
sagesse au sein de la commission la
commission la majorité de la commission
n'était pas tout à fait sur ce point là
nous allons voir donc
cet après-midi ce qu'il en ressortira en
séance et je suis sans évidemment et je
m'y applique avec beaucoup d'intérêt
penser que le gouvernement peut suivre
votre proposition de loi est donné un
avis favorable
alors le gouvernement je ne sais pas
s'il ira jusqu'à suivre et je suis
impatient d'entendre l'avis de la
ministre sur ces questions puisque la
ministre elle-même
roselyne bachelot avait dit qu'elle que
la france n'est d'en haut niveau du
débat européen n'était pas opposé à 18
semaines
il fallait simplement le temps sans
doute donc ce que je me dis est ce que
nous disons nous les sénateurs
socialistes co signataire avec moi de ce
texte c'est que sans doute des choses
dans le débat cet après midi vont nous
permettre de voir les avancées les
avancées dans l'esprit de chacun et y
compris dans l'esprit du gouvernement
ce que je souhaite c'est que donc cela
puisse hier
si ça ne va pas plus loin cet après midi
je le regretterai mais je me prépare
c'est que ça puisse faire évoluer vite
les choses et qu'on en avis arrive
rapidement à la fois un congé maternité
prolongé à une indemnisation meilleur
pour que certaines femmes ne vivent pas
le fait d'une maternité comme une
exclusion en matière notamment
salariales et emploi et donc une
inégalité professionnel avec les hommes
parce que c'est une réalité aussi
et puis je touche aussi toute la
question des non salariés qui
aujourd'hui sont dans une situation
différente
donc on le voit je pense un débat qui va
à venir enrichir la question est qui
nous permettra de déboucher sur d'autres
perspectives
le plus vite possible merci claire-lise
campion d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je vous laisse regagné l'hémicycle du
sénat
à suivre donc l'examen de cette
proposition de loi qui vise à prolonger
le congé maternité très bonne science à
tous l'ordre du jour appelait la
discussion de proposition de loi
relative à la modernisation du congé
maternité en faveur de la protection de
la santé des femmes et l'égalité
salariale et sur les conditions de
l'exercice de la parentalité dans la
discussion générale la parole les
tamalous claire-lise campion auteur et
rapporteur de la proposition de loi
chers collègues nous vous écoutons
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales mes chers
collègues
cette proposition de loi dont je suis la
première signataire est le fruit d'un
constat et d'un contexte le constat est
le suivant malgré la politique familiale
volontariste menée par les pouvoirs
publics depuis le début des années 90
qui explique en grande partie le niveau
élevé des naissances en france la
conciliation des vies familiale et
professionnelle demeure difficile en
particulier pour les parents aux
ressources les plus faibles en outre
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
reste un principe éloigné des réalités
dans les faits les mères continuent
d'assumer l'essentiel des tâches de la
vie quotidienne et des soins aux enfants
et ce sont elles qui en paient le plus
lourd tribut en termes d'emploi et de
carrière professionnelle le contexte lui
est européen le 3 octobre 2008 la
commission européenne a transmis au
conseil et au parlement européen une
proposition de directive relative à la
sécurité et à la santé au travail des
femmes enceintes ou ayant accouché ce
texte qui est une refonte de la
directive fondatrice de 1992 contient
deux mesures phares l'allongement de la
durée minimale européenne du congé de
maternité qui passerait de 14 à 18
semaines
la garantie d'une indemnisation à 100%
du salaire mensuel moyen dans la limite
d'un plafond déterminé par chaque état
membre
notre commission des affaires sociales a
déjà eu l'occasion de s'exprimer sur
cette directive en cours d'élaboration
puisque à l'initiative de notre collègue
annie david
elle a adopté le 27 mai 2009 une
proposition de résolution européenne
devenue résolution du sénat le 15 juin
suivant depuis cette date les
négociations européennes ont suivi leur
cours le 20 octobre dernier
le parlement européen à une très large
majorité à modifier la proposition de
directive en proposant notamment de
porter la durée du congé de maternité à
20 semaines intégralement rémunéré pour
sa part le conseil a consacré en
décembre un débat d'orientation à cette
proposition de directive mais sans
encore parvenir à définir une position
commune lors de ce débat la france s'est
déclarée ouverte à l'idée de porter la
durée du congé de maternité de 14 à 18
semaines mais a indiqué ne pas souhaiter
aller au delà sur la rémunération à 100
% du salaire
elle a considéré que cette proposition
ne serait acceptable que si les états
membres avaient la faculté de définir un
plafond d'indemnisation
je suis convaincu que ces négociations
européennes qui se révèle
particulièrement vives sont l'occasion
d'approfondir le débat sur le plan
national et de faire bouger les lignes
tel est le sens de cette proposition de
loi qui traduit une triple ambition
moderniser le congé de maternité
renforcer la protection juridique des
femmes enceintes ou ayant accouché
qu'elle exerce une activité salarié ou
non salarié et enfin adapter le congé de
paternité aux évolutions des structures
familiales
j'en viens aux mesures proposées pour
atteindre ces objectifs que je
présenterai autour de quatre grands
thèmes premier de ces thèmes
un congé de maternité plus long et mieux
indemniser le congé de maternité une
paix est une période au cours de
laquelle les femmes nous des liens
privilégiés avec leurs enfants liens que
les professionnels de santé estime
essentiel c'est une période de fragilité
durant laquelle tant au niveau physique
que psychologique
la femme doit retrouver un équilibre
c'est également une période charnière
déterminante pour l'avenir de l'enfant
et de la nouvelle famille
actuellement la durée légale de ce congé
en france est de 16 semaines pour les
mères de un ou deux enfants est de 26
semaines pour les mères de trois enfants
ou plus période jugée bien trop courte
tant par les professionnels que par les
mères elles mêmes qui selon une enquête
récente souhaiterait à 84 à 81 4%
qu'elle soit prolongée ces seize
semaines ne permettent pas en effet
d'assurer une transition sereine entre
le nouvel équilibre familial et le
retour à la vie professionnelle
nécessitant la recherche d'un mode de
garde satisfaisant trop vite et trop tôt
la question de l'accueil se pose est
peut être source de culpabilité et de
stress pour bon nombre de maires dont la
préoccupation principale est encore la
relation à leur nouveau-né
ces appréciations sont confirmées par la
pratique puisque la durée moyenne de
l'ensemble des congés effectivement pris
à l'occasion d'une naissance s'élève à
150 jours pour un premier où un deuxième
enfant soit un mois et une semaine de
plus que le seul congé légal de
maternité ses 35 jours supplémentaires
correspondent à la prise de congés
pathologiques et ou à la mobilisation de
jours de congés annuels ou prévues par
les conventions collectives ainsi la
prescription fréquentes par les
professionnels de santé des congés
pathologiques
plus de 70% des femmes mes chers
collègues sont concernés
donc cette prescription aux fréquentes
démontre que la période de
rétablissement psychologique et physique
de la mère dépasse largement la durée
légale du congé de maternité
il paraît donc nécessaire de donner une
dimension législative un cadre juridique
sécurisé et généralisé à ces pratiques
qui correspondent aux besoins de la mère
et de l'enfant
par ailleurs de nombreux facteurs
viennent s'ajouter à la difficulté
d'articuler convenablement vie familiale
et professionnelle
je pense notamment à la détérioration
sensible des conditions de travail
partie due à l'évolution de la
législation sur le travail le dimanche
ou le travail de nuit
l'augmentation du recours aux horaires
décalés ou l'allongement des temps de
trajet entre les lieux d'habitation et
les lieux de pratique professionnelle y
contribuent également
contrairement à une idée reçue la france
n'est pas si généreuse en matière de
durée du congé de maternité
notre pays se situe certes dans la
moyenne des états membres mais derrière
de nombreux pays voisins qui vont du
portugal qui a dit cette semaine de
congé de maternité à l'italie ou au
royaume uni et à lire dans l'irlande
jusqu'à 26 semaines pour ces deux
derniers pays les auteurs de la
proposition de loi sont donc convaincus
qu'un congé de plus longue durée
permettrait aux femmes de se remettre
dans de meilleures conditions de leur
grossesse et de leur accouchement de
passer davantage de temps avec leur
nouveau né de s'occuper des aînés si
nécessaire et d'organiser la vie de la
nouvelle structure familiale le vote
très large de nos collègues députés
européens en octobre dernier en faveur
de l'allongement du congé de maternité
constitue donc un signal très fort
envoyé aux parlementaires nationaux que
nous sommes dans ce double souci
d'amélioration de la santé et de la
sécurité de la mère et de l'enfant et de
conciliation des vies professionnelle et
familiale
l'article 1er de la proposition de loi
propose de porter la durée du congé de
maternité à 20 semaines
il s'agit donc d'un allongement de
quatre semaines et seulement 4 aurais-je
envie d'ajouter à ce titre l'argument de
l'éloignement des femmes du monde du
travail
invoquer pour remettre en cause le congé
parental d'éducation dont la durée peut
aller jusqu'à trois ans n'est pas
recevable
par ailleurs la salariée enceinte a
actuellement droits en contrepartie de
la suspension de son contrat de travail
à des indemnités journalières de
maternité
servi par l'assurance maladie pendant
toute la durée légale de son congé or
ces indemnité égale au salaire
journalier de base diminué de la part
salariale des cotisations sociales et de
la csg
dans la limite du plafond de la sécurité
sociale ne correspondent pas à un
maintien du salaire de ce fait la
maternité continue à être perçue par
certaines femmes comme une sanction
financière
ceci n'est pas respectueux du principe
d'égalité des chances entre les femmes
et les hommes qui impliquerait que les
femmes en congé de maternité ne soient
pas pénalisés financièrement par rapport
à leurs homologues masculins
mes collègues et moi-même estimons qu'un
congé de maternité quelle que soit sa
durée ne sera réellement protecteur que
s'il donne droit au maintien de la
rémunération d'un salarié
c'est pourquoi l'article 4 du texte pose
le principe du versement pendant le
congé de maternité d'une indemnité
compensatrice d'un montant équivalent à
son salaire j'en arrive au deuxième
thème le renforcement de la protection
juridique des femmes salariées enceintes
ou ayant accouché nous savons que la
reprise de l'activité professionnelle
constitue souvent pour la femme qui
vient d'avoir un enfant
un moment délicat comme je le disais car
il lui faut trouver les moyens de
concilier obligations familiales et
professionnelles certaines conventions
collectives prévoient la possibilité
d'adapter les rythmes et horaires de
travail des femmes revenant du congé de
maternité mais tel n'est pas le cas dans
tous les secteurs d'activité afin que
l'ensemble des salariés puisse
bénéficier de telles adaptations
l'article 2 propose que l'entretien
professionnel auquel elles ont droit à
l'issue de leur congé de maternité porte
non seulement sur l'orientation
professionnelle mais aussi sur
l'évolution des conditions et horaires
de travail
cette mesure directement inspirée de la
proposition de directive européenne peu
je crois faire l'objet d'un consensus
parmi nous aujourd'hui
par cohérence avec l'allongement de la
durée du congé de maternité proposé à
l'article 1er est dans un souci de plus
grande protection des femmes enceintes
ou ayant accouché l'article 3 de la
proposition de loi vise à allonger de
deux semaines la période au cours de
laquelle il est interdit d'employer une
salariée avant et après son accouchement
soit dix semaines proposé au total alors
que nous avons huit semaines
actuellement et d'une semaine la période
au cours de laquelle il est interdit
d'employer une salariée après son
accouchement
soit cette semaine après celui ci alors
que six sont concernés actuellement le
troisième thème concerne l'extension des
droits aux femmes exerçant une activité
indépendante
en effet il est urgent de prendre en
considération la situation des femmes
exerçant une activité non salariée
qu'elles soient chefs d'entreprise
femmes artisans commerçante conjointe
collaboratrice exploitante agricole
elles ne peuvent actuellement mettre
entre parenthèses leur travail trop
longtemps au risque de mettre en danger
leurs entreprises le problème se pose
d'ailleurs aussi pour les professions
libérales
la législation française apparaît très
insuffisante pour permettre à toutes ces
mères de vivre pleinement et sereinement
l'expérience de la maternité nombre
d'entre elles sont contraintes de
reprendre rapidement leur activité
bien avant le terme légal fixé pour les
salariés je ne citerai qu'un exemple les
affiliés du régime social des
indépendants qui ne sont pas concernés
par la durée légale du congé de
maternité de 16 semaines ne perçoivent
l'indemnisation journalière forfaitaire
d'interruption d'activité que pendant 74
jours au maximum en cas de naissances
simples
ce qui est très inférieur aux 112 jours
d'indemnités journalières de maternité
qui sont versées par le régime général
afin de remédier à cette inégalité de
fait l'article 5 pose le principe d'une
égalité des droits à congés que
l'activité exercée par les femmes soient
salariés ou non
bien sûr il ne s'agit pas de nier les
spécificités des activités non salariées
les qu'elle impose
plus encore que les activités salariées
de trouver un équilibre entre
obligations professionnelles et
familiales
mais le souci de continuité de
l'entreprise parfaitement légitime et
louable ne saurait justifier que la
santé et la sécurité de la femme
enceinte et celle de son enfant passe au
second plan
dernier thème enfin la création d'un
congé d'accueil de l'enfant
l'instauration du congé de paternité en
2002 est une grande avancée sociale qui
permet au père de s'impliquer davantage
dans l'accueil et l'éducation du nouveau
né
ce congé rencontre d'ailleurs de plus en
plus de succès en effet deux paires sur
trois le prennent toutefois en l'état
actuel du droit seul le père peu après
la naissance de son enfant et dans un
délai de 4 mois bénéficier de ce congé
de 11 jours consécutifs ou 18 en cas de
naissances multiples or depuis plusieurs
décennies la société française connaît
de profonde mutation des structures
familiales
le modèle familial traditionnel fondé
sur un couple composé d'une femme et
d'un homme unis par les liens du mariage
et ayant des enfants communs n'est
certes pas contesté mais il ne constitue
plus le seul mode d'organisation de la
vie familiale ainsi des hommes sont
parfois amenés à participer à
l'éducation d'un enfant qui n'est pas
biologiquement le leur de même au sein
des couples homosexuels
la femme n'ayant pas porter elle-même
l'enfant est tout autant impliqué dans
le projet parental de sa compagne c'est
pour adapter la législation à ces
changements sociétaux que l'article 6
créer un congé d'accueil de l'enfant
destiné non seulement au père biologique
de l'enfant mais aussi au conjoint de la
mère à son concubin ou à son partenaire
de pacs
pendant ce congé de 14 jours consécutifs
21 en cas de naissances multiples la
personne recevra une indemnité
compensatrice d'un montant équivalent à
son salaire enfin je ne ferai que si tu
es rapidement les deux derniers articles
qui organise la mise en oeuvre de la
proposition de loi
l'article 7 qui précise qu'elle
s'appliquera à l'ensemble des femmes en
congé de maternité au moment de sa
publication de l'application de la loi
et l'article 8 qui gâche son financement
sur le relèvement des droits sur les
alcools
tels sont mes chers collègues les
disques
mission de cette proposition de loi
auquel vous l'aurez compris je suis
pleinement favorable
permettez moi avant de conclure mon
propos d'assister sur deux points sur
lesquels je restais à madame la ministre
ne manquera pas de revenir
le premier porte sur les conditions
d'attribution des indemnités
journalières de maternité
lesquels sont loin d'être une réalité
pour toutes les femmes salariées en
effet la condition exigée par
l'assurance maladie des 200 heures
travaillées au cours des trois mois
précédant la date du début de grossesse
ou la date du début du congé par an du
congé prénatal est particulièrement
difficile à remplir pour les femmes qui
sont en situation professionnelle
précaire travaillant à temps partiel ou
en horaire discontinues je pense
notamment aux employés de la grande
distribution ainsi qu'aux intermittente
du spectacle
le second point est de portée plus
générale la modernisation du congé de
maternité que nous préconisons est
indissociable d'une politique familiale
volontariste et ambitieuse en matière de
modes d'accueil qui permettent d'offrir
à chaque ménage la possibilité de faire
garder son ou ses enfants à un coût
raisonnable et malheureusement nous en
sommes encore loin
conformément à l'accord passé entre les
présidents des groupes politiques
la commission des affaires sociales n'a
pas adopté deux textes afin que notre
proposition de loi soit discutée
aujourd'hui dans sa forme initiale
nous avons néanmoins procédé à des
échanges très riches très constructif
sur des sujets aussi importants que le
retour à l'emploi des jeunes mères
l'implication des pères dans l'éducation
des enfants ou les représentations
sociales en matière de partage des
tâches entre les hommes et les femmes
je souhaite quant à moi que nos débats
cet après midi dans l'hémicycle
parviennent à convaincre le sénat du
bien fondé des mesures que cette
proposition de loi comporte et de
l'intérêt de l'adopter je vous remercie
merci monsieur on dans les discussions
générales la parole et à madame roselyne
bachelot narquin ministre des
solidarités et de la cohésion sociale
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteure cercle
r10 campion mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs
je voudrais d'abord vous remercier cher
claire-lise campion de porter à l'examen
du sénat une proposition de loi relative
à la modernisation du congé de maternité
en faveur de la protection de la santé
des femmes et de l'égalité salariale et
sur les conditions d'exercice de la
parentalité
je suis en charge de la famille des
droits des femmes et de l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes et je me
réjouis donc que ces questions soient
abordées dans notre pays comme elles le
sont d'ailleurs au niveau européen
comment ne pas souscrire à votre constat
initial
j'ai déjà moi même souvent rappeler
l'absolue nécessité de mieux concilier
vie familiale et vie professionnelle et
de garantir un meilleur partage des
responsabilités familiales et
professionnelles
ce sont des exigences incontournables si
nous voulons faire avancer les droits
des femmes mais aussi bâtir les
conditions d'une société plus juste et
plus humaine
pour autant si je partage votre constat
je le répète je discuterai des moyens
que vous proposez aujourd'hui
en effet comme dans toute bonne
négociation avant de demander
l'application d'un accord pour améliorer
les droits des femmes
je préfère évalué préalablement les
différents intérêts en jeu
j'essaie également d'imaginer des pistes
permettant de procurer à bénéfice mutuel
ou femme mais aussi à l'ensemble de des
entreprises et à l'état évidemment une
avancée sociale ou en effet contribuer à
faire progresser l'intérêt général être
partagé par tous
c'est pourquoi je vous proposerai tout à
l'heure de nous investir d'abord dans la
négociation collective d'en explorer les
différents compromis possible avant de
vouloir légiférer ou de prendre des
dispositions de type réglementaire mais
je vais reprendre les quatre thématiques
contenues dans votre proposition de loi
et vous livrer à leur sujet mon
sentiment qui est évidemment celui du
gouvernement
première thématique autour de laquelle
vous articulé vos propositions instaurer
un congé de maternité plus long mieux
indemnisés pour mémoire je rappelle les
difficultés de nos finances publiques
qui nous permettent pas actuellement
d'envisager des dépenses nouvelles qui
aurait pour conséquence d'augmenter les
déficits publics ainsi que les charges
des entreprises puisque pour l'instant
nous finançons notre politique sociale
largement à crédit
je me suis déjà exprimé sur le sujet
lors du dernier conseil dit abscons
conseil des affaires sociales de 6
décembre dernier sans les surestimer
au delà des coûts nets je rappelle ce
que cela représente pour la sécurité
sociale pour deux semaines à 170
millions d'euros si nous passons donc de
16 à 18 semaines dans le dispositif
actuel d'indemnisation
je vous rappelle que les règles
actuelles d'indemnisation du congé de
maternité français avoisine les 95 4% du
salaire net de l'assuré dans la limite
d'un plafond égal au 1er janvier 2011 à
2009 146 euros à 340 millions d'euros
pour quatre semaines signe donc nous
passons congé de 16 à 20 semaines
si nous acceptions la disposition votée
par le parlement européen qui dès
plafonne le montant de 2009 140 euros la
dépense nouvelle s'élèverait à plus de
1,1 milliard d'euros
donc en prenant comme référence la
totalité du salaire réel c'est
évidemment une dépense qui est
inenvisageable dans dans l'état actuel
de nos finances publiques
concernant les employeurs ajouterais-je
il pourrait constituer dans certains cas
dans certains cas un frein à l'embauché
au développement de leur carrière leur
progression salariale
nous avons d'ailleurs
quelques alliés contestable dans ce
domaine qui verrait une possibilité de
ramener les femmes les femmes chez elle
ne leur permettant pas ainsi le libre
choix entre une carrière professionnelle
et le fait de rester à la maison
les conditions de retour à l'emploi dans
les entreprises privées ainsi que dans
le cadre de l'exercice de professions
libérales peuvent être compliquées en
france comme dans l'ensemble des pays
européens
je souhaite donc au préalable une
expertise approfondie soit menée pour
bien cerner les conséquences réelles
qu'aurait un allongement de la durée des
congés sur ces cas particuliers
lorsqu'on veut les comparaisons avec
certains pays étrangers
mais ces comparaisons peuvent comporter
des billets d'évaluation important par
exemple en suède pays qui bénéficient
d'une législation sociale très avancé
protectrice après un an de congé
parental pour la naissance d'un enfant
les maires intègre en fait en quasi
totalité le secteur public
car oui ce secteur public garanti
l'effectivité du retour à l'emploi
mais pas nécessairement les entreprises
privées ou les conditions de
fonctionnement et de gestion des
ressources humaines sont évidemment
beaucoup plus contraintes et ses
difficultés nous ne pouvons les ignorer
comparaison n'est donc pas raison c'est
pourquoi j'insiste sur la priorité de
recourir d'abord à un approfondissement
préalable par la négociation collective
dans ce cadre il faut impérativement
articulé deux priorités la préservation
de la santé des femmes la promotion de
l'égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes est de vous l'avez
d'ailleurs bien bien rappeler si d'un
point de vue de la santé des femmes
l'allongement du congé de maternité se
justifie il peut constituer notamment
dans certains métiers du secteur privé
un frein plus ou moins importants à
l'emploi et à la promotion des femmes
nous en avons chacune et chacun un
certain nombre d'exemples regrettable
certes mais que l'on est obligé de
constater par conséquent il nous faut
éviter qu'un allongement souhaitable du
congé de maternité puisse aboutir à un
résultat contraire à l'intérêt à la
promotion sociale des femmes dans
certaines professions
nous ne pouvons accepter que cet
allongement puisse organiser un retrait
plus long des femmes du marché du
travail et des interruptions d'activité
qui pèseront sur leur niveau de
rémunération leur retraite deuxième
thématique de votre proposition
renforcer la protection juridique des
femmes salariées enceintes ou ayant
accouché l'entretien professionnel
auquel les femmes ont droit à l'issue de
leur congé de maternité doit porter non
seulement sur leur orientation
professionnelle mais aussi sur leur sur
l'évolution de leurs conditions et
horaires de travail
là aussi avant la mise en oeuvre d'une
mesure législative
il est essentiel d'engager une
discussion approfondie avec les
partenaires sociaux
et cette mesure relève surtout du
domaine de la négociation et des
conventions collectives comme vous
l'avez précisé lors de la commission du
25 mai dernier
certaines conventions collectives
prévoient d'ailleurs déjà la possibilité
d'adapter les rythmes et horaires de
travail des femmes revenant d'un congé
de maternité mais ce n'est pas le cas
partout
pour y parvenir il faut donc faire mûrir
des esprits certains esprits et
rechercher de nouveaux points de
consensus
vous soulignez que cette mesure est
directement inspirée de la proposition
de directive européenne j'avais
d'ailleurs fait juste remarquer le 6
décembre dernier lors du dernier conseil
epsco emploi politique sociale santé
protection des consommateurs relatifs à
l'emploi et aux affaires sociales que
les options du parlement européen
tenet insuffisamment compte du principe
de subsidiarité et qu'elle laissait trop
peu de place au dialogue social
il est nécessaire d'approfondir les
pistes qui permettent d'établir les
liens entre les différentes formes de
congés familiaux vers opéré à vous mr
notamment de congé de paternité
il faut se donner le temps d'explorer
les options de discuter avec les
partenaires sociaux qui doivent être
étroitement associés à ce dossier
je serais plutôt favorable à
l'établissement au préalable d'un
constat précis des difficultés actuelles
sur le marché du travail en termes de
protection de même
il est nécessaire d'évaluer les
conséquences de cette mesure sur le
marché du travail des femmes
son degré d'efficacité ses coûts pour
l'entreprise d'assurance maladie l'état
on ne peut pas prendre de décision sans
avoir un tableau précis des différents
besoins de financement j'en viens
maintenant à la troisième thématique
étendre les droits des femmes enceintes
exerçant une activité indépendante et à
la 4è créer un congé d'accueil de
l'enfant comme pour la deuxième
thématique
j'ai tendance à juger plus en plus
adéquat l'engagement préalable d'une
négociation avec les partenaires sociaux
une évaluation des difficultés actuelles
des coûts pour les différentes parties
de l'efficacité des conséquences d'une
telle mesure sur le marché du travail
je souligne également que pour les
femmes exerçant en libéral pour
lesquelles je le rappelle j'ai pris un
certain nombre de dispositions dans les
derniers plfss
il est légitime de souligner un autre
inconvénient puisque effectivement le
congé de maternité c'est aussi la
garantie de retrouver son emploi dans
les termes même où on l'a quitté et
qu'effectivement on ne peut pas apporter
cette garantie aux femmes exerçant au
libéral puisque
on peut leur faire ce congé peut leur
faire courir le risque de perdre une
partie de leur clientèle
vous l'avez compris de nombreux aspects
de cette proposition de loi me semble
devoir encore être réfléchie examiné
avec beaucoup d'attention pour nous
assurer que nous allons bien dans le
sens d'une juste et durable conciliation
entre vie familiale et vie
professionnelle
l'ensemble des aspects particuliers
doivent être préalablement régler avant
d'aborder la phase des législatives
et de rappeler qu'on ne peut résoudre la
politique familiale de notre pays
extrêmement ambitieuse où seul congé de
maternité la politique familiale de
notre pays a de très importantes
qualités qui sont saluées remarquer
reconnu par nos partenaires européens
nous y consacrons le double de l'effort
financier de la moyenne des autres pays
européens
nous y consacrons 5,1 pour cent de notre
produit intérieur brut en 2007 se
rappelle que cette cette part n'était
que de 4 7% au début du quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy
c'est remarquable et grâce à cette
politique nous obtenons les meilleurs
résultats en europe pour la natalité en
ayant un des taux d'activité les plus
élevés pour les femmes dans donc en
france vous savez l'avenir de notre pays
se joue aussi sur le renouvellement des
générations
il faut donc engagé la négociation
collective au préalable pour faire
progresser les droits des femmes comme
aucun texte de loi n'est parfait il faut
que la réponse aux contraintes que fait
peser la maternité sur l'activité
professionnelle des femmes puissent être
déterminé au cas par cas selon les
besoins les spécificités des branches
professionnelles pour s'adapter aux
différences qui existent entre le
travail dans la fonction publique et
dans le secteur privé il faut introduire
plus de souplesse
encadrés par la loi après la novation la
négociation collective afin d'assurer le
respect des principes fondamentaux du
droit du travail dans les relations
entre employeurs et salariés pour
permettre aux femmes qui souhaitent
reprendre le travail plus rapidement
après leur accouchement de le faire et
ne pas figer le dispositif du congé de
maternité
il me paraît utile d'étudier
parallèlement des dispositifs protecteur
de nature législative
sociale pour les femmes exerçant en
libéral ou des fonctions de cadre
supérieur en entreprise comme l'a
souligné le sénateur andré lardeux je
pense important de régler les aspects
des cas particuliers comme la naissance
d'un enfant handicapé ou la mère doit
pouvoir bénéficier de mesures
d'accompagnement d'être supplémentaires
ou comme l'adoption avec la prise en
compte des besoins spécifiques que cette
adoption implique enfin nous devons
maîtriser les coûts pour les finances
publiques
réfléchir aux modes de financement de
ces mesures nouvelles le moyen d'une
augmentation des droits sur les alcools
n'est pas satisfaisant vous en
conviendrez vous même en outre la tenue
prochaine à conseil epsco le 17 juin va
dans le même sens il me paraît plus un
peu opportun de réserver notre position
en attendant les prochaines évolutions
ce qui est certain c'est que sur le
sujet nous devons d adopter une vision
une approche globale qui prenne en
compte le congé de maternité mais aussi
l'articulation de l'ensemble des congés
qui existent actuellement pour conserver
la cohérence du dispositif actuel
étudier des conditions de l'intégration
des femmes au sein du marché du travail
de la répartition des rôles et des
responsabilités entre les femmes et les
hommes ou encore de l'accueil de la
petite enfance ses différentes
dimensions sont liées elles seront
abordés lors de la conférence sur
l'égalité professionnelle et familiale
que j'organise avec xavier bertrand à la
fin du mois faire claire-lise campion
votre proposition de loi ouvre un
important dossier dont je partage la
philosophie si je n'approuve pas ce
texte
aujourd'hui si je ne peux pas
l'approuver en l'état je veux redire que
je réaffirme mon engagement en faveur
des droits des femmes et de l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes
vous avez donc ouvert un important
dossier qui méritent d'être affinés et
encore mieux étudier mais je suis sûr
que c'était le sens de votre proposition
de loi je vous remercie de votre travail
merci le ministre dans la suite de
discussions
la parole à notre collègue marie thérèse
bruguière apparenté ump
merci monsieur le président madame le
ministre mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
chers collègues l'articulation de la vie
professionnelle et familiale étonnamment
jeu vrai pour les femmes d'aujourd'hui
qui pour la plupart souhaitent concilier
les deux dans les meilleures conditions
possibles
il est donc de notre responsabilité de
prendre toute la mesure de la
problématique en présence à savoir le
cadre juridique du congé maternité pour
apporter des solutions appropriées
en l'occurrence ce n'est pas le cas de
la proposition de loi dont nous avons à
débattre aujourd'hui je le regrette
elle a néanmoins le mérite de soulever
des questions importantes pour les
femmes
et de rappeler l'objectif qui doit être
sans cesse poursuivi d'une meilleure
protection des femmes dans notre société
la principale objection du groupe ump
que je représente concerne la
prolongation de la durée du congé de
maternité de quatre semaines
bien que séduisant ce dispositif
s'appelle s'avère peu pertinent voire
contre productif en se retournant contre
les femmes concernées le risque est réel
de fragiliser la situation des femmes
dans les entreprises
pour les employeurs cela est en effet
susceptible de représenter des
contraintes importantes
par ailleurs un amant cette mesure
pourrait constituer un frein à
l'embauché facteur de discrimination
constamment dénoncé mais difficilement
maîtrisable dans les faits et ce
d'autant plus que le dispositif proposé
du salaire pendant cette période
constitue des contraintes
supplémentaires que toutes les
entreprises ne pourraient pas supporter
sans conséquence
la situation actuelle nous connaissons
les emplois partielles concernent
majoritairement les femmes celles-ci au
moins facilement accès aux postes
importants
rappelons qu'un cadre sur quatre est une
femme et des différences injustifiée de
salaire persistent quant au chômage
nous savons que les femmes sont plus
frappés que les hommes faut-il en
rajouter les difficultés sont réelles et
le constat de la nécessité d'une
meilleure protection de la femme
et partager mes noces une solution
différente
tout d'abord il convient de s'interroger
sur ce que souhaitent les femmes dans ce
domaine
elles seraient plus nombreuses à
préférer un congé plus court mais mieux
rémunéré et des modes de garde facilité
selon une enquête du credoc 70% des
familles
le déclarant nous devons aussi nous
pencher sur ce qui existe déjà comme le
congé parental d'éducation qui permet
suite à une naissance ou à une adoption
à tout salarié d'interrompre ou de
réduire son activité professionnelle
pour élever cet enfant est le congé de
paternité qui permet à la demande de
bénéficier d'un congé indemniser d'une
durée de 11 à 18 jours calendaires par
ailleurs il convient de saluer une
mesure gouvernementale récents dans
faveur des femmes non salariée qui a
pour objet d'étendre le congé maternité
aux femmes relevant du régime social des
indépendants et du régime agricole ainsi
que conjointe collaboratrice des assurés
relevant du rsi en outre il faut
souligner l'efficacité de la politique
familiale menée actuellement par le
gouvernement et notamment celle de la
petite enfance avec 826 1000 naissances
en mille en 2010 la france bénéficie
d'un dynamisme démographique important
dans le gouvernement a mesuré
l'importance près de 90 milliards
d'euros sont consacrés à la politique
familiale soit deux fois plus que la
moyenne des autres pays européens
le gouvernement s'est déjà engagé à
créer 200 mille places de garde
supplémentaires d'ici 2012
c'est la démarche a préconisé à
amplifier la priorité absolue doit être
dans la même que celle des mères de
famille
la création des modes de garde
diversifiés
c'est donc dans ce domaine précis que
l'action publique doit se concentrer
dans un souci constant d'efficacité et
des deux familles
enfin les dispositions de la proposition
de loi qui nous est soumise tout misé
pardon générerait des dépenses
supplémentaires conséquente au niveau
des finances sociales qui connaissent
déjà
comme viennent de le souligner madame la
ministre d'importantes difficultés quant
à la place des femmes dans l'entreprise
elle doit suivre sa progression de façon
toujours plus soutenu les résultats
seront là si les entreprises se sentent
pleinement associés et non contrainte
dans le cas contraire ce sont une
nouvelle fois les femmes qui risquent de
n'être finalement les victimes
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
dans la suite des discussions générales
la parole est à notre collègue roselle
cros pour le groupe union centriste
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues
la présente proposition de loi aborde un
sujet qui nous concerne tous et
particulièrement les femmes et dans cet
hémicycle nul ne saurait remettre en
cause la nécessité d'adapter le congé de
maternité aux évolutions du milieu du
travail que ce soit l'accroissement du
pourcentage de la population active
féminine ou là leur mouvement généralisé
des temps de transports notamment en
région ile de france
en témoigne la résolution de notre haute
assemblée du 15 juin 2009 portant sur ce
thème ainsi d'ailleurs que la position
exprimée par la france dans le cadre de
la révision de la directive de 92 à
l'initiative des institutions
européennes voulant garantir un meilleur
équilibre entre vie professionnelle et
vie privée mais aussi mieux protéger les
travailleuses enceintes
la commission a proposé une directive
temps d'en allonger et à encadrer la
durée du congé de maternité à améliorer
son indemnisation et à renforcer la
protection juridique des femmes
enceintes
la directive prévoit aussi
l'assouplissement des rythmes et
horaires de travail et le renversement
de la charge de la preuve
si le processus de co législation
européen est avancé aucun accord des
pics définitif n'est encore intervenue
les aucune position commune a été
adoptée sur ce texte
vous me permettrez d'observer à
l'occasion de cette proposition de loi
que l'intervention européenne mérite
davantage notre approbation dans ce rôle
social de protection surtout lorsqu elle
tend vers une harmonisation par le haut
que lorsqu elle édicte des normes
techniques contraignants dont le citoyen
ne comprend pas toujours l'intérêt c'est
donc dans ce contexte européen que
s'inscrit la présente proposition de loi
nous ne pouvons que souscrire à ces
objectifs
elle s'inscrit dans le cadre d'une
politique de santé
vie familiale et bien qu'aucune
corrélation de soit établie entre la
générosité du dispositif d'un pays donné
et sa dynamique de natalité le congé
maternité est un outil de la politique
démographique de notre pays
comme l'est le développement des modes
de garde de la petite enfance
si les intentions sont louables et
mérite donc d'être débattue en revanche
nous ne jugeons pas toutes les mesures
proposées des plus pertinentes
examinons les l'article premier propose
de faire passer la durée du congé de
maternité de 16 à 20 semaines soit un
allongement de quatre semaines il est
vrai que comme le monde très bien le
rapport la france ne figure pas au
nombre des pays les plus généreux dans
ce domaine cependant le passage brutal
de 16 à 20 semaines est excessif et
poserait nombre de problèmes pratiques
et financier en effet s'il convient de
permettre à la mère d'accueillir à
nouveau né dans les meilleures
conditions
il ne faut pas non plus perdre de vue
l'impératif de sa réinsertion
professionnelle et de son retour à
l'emploi
après une longue coupure une logique de
protection qui ne laisse aucune
souplesse aux femmes notamment pour
répartir leurs congés avant et après
l'accouchement ne tient pas suffisamment
compte de la réalité du milieu
professionnel ni des contraintes du
monde du travail
c'est particulièrement vrai pour les
femmes qui occupent des postes de
responsabilité ou qui travaillent en
indépendante ou tout simplement qui
choisissent de consacrer tout leur congé
à leurs nouveaux nés après sa naissance
on observe aussi que beaucoup de femmes
et pas seulement des cadres durant le
projet de maternité veulent maintenir un
lien avec leur travail et leurs
collègues pour ne pas perdre le fil est
de mieux préparer leur retour
raison pour laquelle nous serions
favorables au rallongement du congé de
maternité de deux semaines seulement
pour le faire passer de 16
dix huit semaines une position dure est
conforme à la position exprimée par la
france dans le cadre de la proposition
européenne men en tout état de cause
cette disposition ne s'est pas à elle
seule une loi et il serait évidemment
très prématuré de se prononcer
maintenant sur tous les autres aspects
du texte alors que le conseil n'est pas
parvenu à définir une position commune
et nous serions contraints dans une
transposition en droit national de
revenir sur un texte que nous viendrions
tout juste d'adopter l'article 2 propose
le maintien intégral du salaire pendant
le congé de maternité en remplacement du
système actuel aujourd'hui le congé de
maternité n'est à deniz et qu'à hauteur
du salaire journalier brute diminuée de
la part salariale des cotisations
sociales et de la csg et dans la limite
du plafond de la sécurité sociale
il s'agirait d' adopter une mesure dont
le financement n'est pas assurée et dont
le coût est malheureusement connue un
milliard d'euros à prendre en charge par
l'assurance maladie
si la durée du congé et porter à 18
semaines
est il opportun d'accroître le déficit
en ces temps difficiles on aux finances
publiques
c'est pourquoi nous souscrivons
pleinement à la position de sagesse
préconisées par le gouvernement à
l'échelon européen en vertu de laquelle
une indemnisation à 100% de salaire est
envisageable mais dans la limite d'un
plafond défini par chaque état
l'article 5 étant aux femmes exerçant
une activité non salariée les droits des
femmes salariées en matière de congé de
maternité
l'intention est certes généreuse mais
peu réaliste prenons l'exemple que je
connais bien des femmes exploitantes
agricoles
tout le monde connaît les difficultés
rencontrées par les agriculteurs qui
veulent se faire remplacer pour prendre
une à deux semaines de congés annuels
seulement comment imaginer un
remplacement de 10
huit semaines le problème est toujours
les mêmes
en créant des droits de façon très
générale sans tenir compte des
spécificités des métiers ou des secteurs
professionnels ont fini par créer des
inégalités
avant la loi une arche gonflable
consitait concertation serait
souhaitable
avec la pluie comme l'a souligné madame
le ministre de négociation collective
par secteur quant à l'article 6 qui crée
un congé d'accueil de l'enfant au
bénéfice du conjoint de la mère de son
concubin ou de son partenaire de pacs
ils tentent d'adapter et c'est louable
le droit à l'évolution de la société
mais dans sa rédaction actuelle il
manque de clarté juridique et on peut le
regretter il ne bénéficie pas aux
parents adoptants quant à souk où il
n'est pas chiffré pour toutes ces
raisons
si nous comprenons l'initiative de
claire lise campion et de ses collègues
si nous saluons la qualité de son
travail de rapporteur la richesse des
débats et reconnaissons l'importance de
ce débat moi même et les membres du coup
du groupe de l'union centriste et simon
que ce texte ne peut pas être adopté en
l'état
aujourd'hui je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci ne fait que l'aig dans la suite
des discussions générales la parole et
françoise laborde pour le groupe rdse
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues notre assemblée
débat aujourd'hui d'un sujet qui
pourrait constituer une avancée notable
pour les femmes en france
tirant les conclusions de la proposition
de directive adoptée par le parlement
européen le 20 octobre dernier la
proposition de loi du groupe socialiste
suggère de porter la durée du congé de
maternité à 20 semaines
le législateur européen a instauré un
droit plus protecteur améliorant
l'indemnisation du congé de maternité
ainsi que la protection contre le
licenciement de la femme enceinte ou de
la jeune mère permettant aux femmes
reprenant le travail
un aménagement des rythmes et horaires
de travail dans le sens de leur
assouplissement ou encore appliquant le
renversement de la charge de la preuve
en cas d'infraction de l'employeur un
congé plus long et mieux indemniser une
protection renforcée des femmes
enceintes en activité salarié ou non
salarié une implication renforcée des
pères voici en quelques mots les
avancées proposées par la proposition de
loi socialiste et je félicite notre
collègue claire lise campion d'en avoir
pris l'initiative
cette évolution vers un droit plus
protecteur n'est pourtant pas sans
soulever des inquiétudes ou des
réticences en effet que ce soit d'une
part en matière de lutte contre les
discriminations liées à la grossesse
envers les femmes sur le marché du
travail d'autre part en matière de
financement de ces mesures ou encore de
définition de l'homme bénéficiaires du
congé de paternité
tout reste encore à pérenniser outre
l'argument de la santé des femmes
enceintes ou de l'égalité des chances
dans le domaine professionnel face à la
maternité
l'élément qui peut nous rassembler c'est
la politique en faveur de la natalité
en effet l'union européenne dans son
ensemble est confrontée au défi de la
démocratie et du vieillissement de nos
populations et notre pays ne fait pas
l'exception
les orientations proposées par cette
proposition de loi vont dans le bon sens
à long terme
cela devrait nous obliger à mettre en
parallèle des aménagements afin que les
répercussions sur le marché du travail
ne pèse pas davantage sur les très
petites entreprises ni par conséquent
sur la précarisation des carrières des
femmes
les premiers mois qui suivent la
naissance ont une période très
importante pour la mère et pour son
nouveau né comme le démontrent les
pédopsychiatres dans leurs publications
scientifiques
c'est pendant ce moment précis qu'il
tisse des liens se découvre et s'attache
l'un à l'autre pourtant les mentalités
n'ont pas encore intégré ce constat
comme une priorité d'ordre sociétal une
res une récente enquête de la caisse
nationale de l'assurance maladie des
travailleurs salariés démontre
d'ailleurs qu'allonger la durée du congé
de maternité répond à une atteinte haye
par don à une attente forte de
nombreuses femmes et que la majorité de
maires prend un congé de maternité plus
long il s'agit souvent de congés
supplémentaires dit pathologique prix
après l'accouchement pour permettre aux
mères d'allaiter plus long temps de se
remettre de leur grossesse ou de gérer
tout simplement une petite dépression
post partum
c'est pourquoi je souscris à la mise en
place d'un congé d'accueil de l'enfant
d'une durée de 14 jours qui permettra
aux pères souvent frustré au début mais
à l'écart de tisser des liens avec leurs
enfants d'épauler la mère de s'occuper
des autres enfants ou de la maison je
voudrais évoquer plus longuement les
comptes questions de discrimination à
l'égard des femmes salariées
certains soulignent que l'allongement du
congé de maternité à 20 semaines
creuserait davantage les inégalités
entre les hommes et les femmes
malheureusement ces inégalités existent
déjà et persiste dans son dernier
rapport la halde fait état de 618
réclamations pour discrimination liée à
la grossesse sur l'année 2010 si la
plupart ont lieu pendant ou autour de la
grossesse
certaines se traduisent par l'évincement
des femmes par anticipation
dès l'entretien si elle déclare qu'elle
envisage d'avoir un enfant selon une
étude csa 23% des sondés déclarent avoir
été interrogée lors d'un entretien
d'embauché sur leur volonté ou non de
devenir mère un jour cette proposition
de loi met donc en exergue de madame la
ministre
un véritable problème de société le rôle
et la place des hommes le rôle et la
place des femmes dans un souci d'égalité
et dans l'intérêt des enfants et des
familles tout au long du xxème siècle
les femmes
il faut leur rendre hommage se sont
battus pour mettre un terme aux
inégalités et aux discriminations
à force de revendication de mouvements
sociaux et de propositions de lois comme
celles que nous défendons aujourd'hui
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
a progressé
toutefois dans les faits il subsiste
encore beaucoup trop d'inégalités gelé
dénoncé à maintes reprises lors des
débats que nous avons eus en octobre
dernier à l'occasion de la réforme des
retraites
les femmes gagnent en moyenne 10 9% de
moins que les hommes elles sont
surreprésentées dans les emplois à temps
partiel à durée déterminée ou à bas
salaire et sont les plus touchés par le
chômage et cette situation ne cesse de
s'amplifier
lorsqu'elles deviennent mères aussi
madame la ministre cette proposition de
loi doit être l'occasion d'engager une
réflexion plus globale sur la société et
ses évolutions
elle doit ouvrir la voie à une politique
familiale plus ambitieuse nous devons
relever le défi de l'aménagement du togo
du temps de travail socialement
acceptable pour l'ensemble des femmes
qui entendent concilier leur vie
familiale et leur carrière
professionnelle sans nuire ni à l'une ni
à l'autre même si l'on tient compte de
l'évolution du rôle des nouveaux pères
les changements de mentalités sont lents
les tâches domestiques et l'éducation
des enfants sont encore aujourd'hui la
sphère des femmes
qui doivent mener de front une double
journée et sont confrontés à des
contraintes telles que les horaires de
crèche ou la garde des enfants malades
je ne reviendrai pas ici sur la
problématique posée par les carences en
matière de structures d'accueil pour la
garde d'enfants avec un besoins évoluent
évalué à 400 mille places pour éviter
que les femmes soient toujours les
premières victimes de temps partiel subi
avec des conséquences sur leur carrière
et leur retraite
je ne peux qu'être favorable à l'article
2 de la proposition de loi qui prévoit
que l'entretien professionnel auquel les
salariés endroit à l'issue de leur congé
maternité porte sur l'évolution de leurs
conditions et horaires de travail
oui des écueils se trouveront sur le
chemin
le congé de maternité est une question
sensible au sein des entreprises
oui il nous faudra arbitrer pour trouver
les financements nécessaires
oui il s'agit bien d'un choix de société
que nous devons faire en favorisant
ainsi la maternité
nous espérons le de relever le défi
démographique et celui de la natte
natalité mais celui de l'égalité
cela a un coût sommes nous prêts à
l'assumer pour toutes ces raisons la
majorité des sénateurs du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen votera
avec conviction ce texte je vous
remercie
merci on sûr que lingue ou dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole et
dany david pour le groupe crc spg
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je ne reviendrai pas
sur le vote du parlement européen ça a
été largement fait sauf à dire qu'il
dépasse la proposition de la commission
européenne et qu'il dépasse également
madame la ministre la volonté de votre
gouvernement qui souhaitait se contenter
au cours de ce débat de 18 semaines de
congé maternité
s'il reste encore beaucoup à faire pour
tendre à une harmonisation vers le haut
des droits sociaux au sein de l'union
européenne il s'agit malgré tout d'un
pas important dont je me réjouis une
fois n'est pas coutume la commission
européenne confortée par le parlement à
proposer une harmonisation certes pas
vers le haut mais médiane puisque la
durée du congé maternité varient de
façon importante dans d'un état à
l'autre avec une moyenne qui se situe
entre 16 et 25 semaines vous l'avez
rappelé madame la rapporteure ans en
citant l'angleterre pour ma part je
citerai la slovaquie qui l octroi 28
semaines de congé maternité vous le
voyez la france avec ses seize semaines
se situent donc parmi les pays les moins
bien placés
d'ailleurs certaines femmes je vous ai
écouté avec attention madame la ministre
d'ailleurs certaines femmes pour
augmenter leur congé postnatal s'appuie
sur la loi du 5 mars 2007 qui leur
permet de reporter au maximum trois
semaines de leur congé prénatal
or ce congé répondent à des impératifs
de santé publique pour la mère comme
pour l'enfant
nous avons d'ailleurs adopté sa a été
rappelé aussi ici à la commission des
affaires sociales le 27 mai 2009 une
proposition européenne dans ce sens qui
est devenu vous l'avez dit une
résolution du sénat le 15 juin suivant
j'y reviendrai dans un moment au cours
de l'article 1
la balle est donc dans le camp des
gouvernements européens et la france se
doit d'être au rendez vous vous en avez
l'opportunité madame la ministre
mais le débat de ce matin en commission
ne me laisse que peu d'espoir d'aboutir
bien au contraire il me met même très en
colère en effet entendre comme cela
était le cas ce matin que les femmes ne
peuvent pas vouloir le
beurre et l'argent du beurre me met
véritablement en colère ces propos sont
indignes de notre assemblée et il est
terrifiant de constater encore de nos
jours que des hommes parce qu'ils ne
savent pas ce que c'est que porter un
enfant certains hommes des hommes j'ai
bien dis pas les hommes mon cher
collègue ronan que certains hommes parce
qu'ils ne savent pas ce que c'est que de
porter un enfant de le métro man tout en
travaillant puisse encore penser de la
sorte
et oui ça me met en colère de même les
arguments invoqués par votre collègue
lors du débat à l'assemblée nationale et
que vous avez repris madame la ministre
ici même me met en colère prétexté des
contraintes budgétaires en évaluant le
coût de cette mesure à 1,3 milliard
d'euros par an n'est pas recevable la
santé des femmes et des enfants ne se
négocie pas elle impose au contraire
qu'on prenne nos responsabilités
je reprendrai a à mon compte les mots de
mon collègue roland muzeau
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale en
effet mieux vaut être restaurateur que
femmes enceintes car le coût de la
mesure de la baisse de la tva a été
absorbée par l'état et le coût du congé
maternité lui ne le serait pas alors oui
il s'agit de santé publique et il faut
prendre vos responsabilités madame la
ministre d'ailleurs un récent rapport de
votre majorité se prononce pour un
allongement du congé maternité car je
cite il possède un grand nombre d'effets
bénéfiques dont il permet aux mamans
d'établir un lien privilégié avec leurs
enfants dans les premiers mois de la vie
qui sont considérés par différents
pédiatre comme déterminant pour l'enfant
et le regrettable constat du frein à
l'embauché dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure madame la ministre
ce n'est pas seulement un regrettable
constat c'est un constat qu'il faut
combattre
en outre avec un taux d'activité féminin
de près de 80% l'accueil de la petite
enfance est devenue un enjeu majeur pour
la conciliation vie familiale et vie
professionnelle ainsi dans son rapport
au premier ministre michèle tabarot
estime que 25 % des parents qui se sont
arrêtés pour garder leurs enfants ont
choisi cette solution est bien souvent
ces mamans faute d'avoir une autre
solution cette insuffisance explique
pourquoi en 35 ans malgré l'arrivée
massive des femmes sur le marché du
travail
la part des emplois occupés à temps
partiel est passée de 13% à 37 %
bien sûr des femmes et parmi elles trois
sur quatre souhaiteraient occuper un
emploi à temps plein mais pour nous la
solution ne passe pas pour autant par la
création de jardins d'éveil annie la
diversification de structures d'accueil
mais par la mise en oeuvre d'un
véritable service public de la petite
enfance avec une augmentation du nombre
de places offertes
il en manque selon les estimations entre
200000 à 400000 le développement des
moyens de garde n'est pas contradictoire
avec l'allongement du congé maternité au
contraire les deux sont une nécessité
pour permettre aux femmes de mieux
articuler leur activité professionnelle
et leur vie familiale
concernant le reste de la proposition
est donc la proposition de maintenir
dans son intégralité le salaire proposé
également par la commission et le
parlement européens nous y souscrivons
pleinement car elle répond à une mesut
mesure d'équité
en effet il n'existe actuellement aucune
obligation de maintenir le salaire sauf
conventions collectives ou accords de
branche ce qui fait que selon les
secteurs
les femmes les femmes n'ont pas les
mêmes droits toutefois afin de parfaire
la protection de la femme enceinte un
autre point mériterait d'être abordée
cela concerne les femmes contraintes de
s'arrêter de travailler pour des raisons
de santé liées à leur état de grossesse
bien avant le congé pathologique ou
maternité
cette période est assimilée à une
maladie et elle est en conséquence et
génératrice d'inégalités mesures
viendraient lors de l'examen de
l'article 1
un autre point sur lequel je souhaite
attirer l'attention de cette haute
assemblée est votre attention madame la
ministre madame la rapporteure l'a
d'ailleurs rappelé concerne la
discrimination dont sont victimes
notamment les femmes soumises au régime
des intermittents du spectacle en effet
elle se voit fréquemment refusé
l'indemnisation de leurs congés
maternité par la sécurité sociale en
raison de la discontinuité de leur
emploi elles sont doublement pénalisés
et car n'ayant pas obtenu l'ouverture de
leurs droits à la sécurité sociale elles
se voient également refuser l'accès à
l'indemnisation chômage
cette absence de protection sociale pour
toute une partie de nos concitoyennes
est indigne de notre république
de nombreuses mères victimes de ce
système regroupés sous un collectif les
matermittentes ont d'ailleurs saisi la
halde
à ce sujet un mot avant de conclure sur
les autres points
l'extension proposée du congé paternité
redéfinie en congé d'accueil pour
l'enfant et son allongement à 14 jours
cette mesure va dans le bon sens nous
semble-t-il je relèverai également
peut-être quelques-uns incertitudes
quant à la rédaction juridique et au
fait qu'il faudrait prendre garde à ne
pas porter atteinte à l'autorité
parentale quant à l'article 5
il apporte des droits nouveaux aux
femmes non salariés nous y souscrivons
donc pleinement
ainsi cette ppl répond à une nécessité
et nous devons aller plus loin encore
mes chers collègues
quoi que vous en disiez quoi que vous en
pensiez car si la france possède le
deuxième indice de fécondité européen
avec 1,98 enfant par femme en 2009
c'est parce que la plupart d'entre elles
peuvent continuer à travailler même si
ce n'est à temps partiel toutes les
mesures les aidant à concilier travail
et famille ainsi que la valorisation par
la société de leur double casquette
favorise la participation des femmes sur
le marché du travail tout en soutenant
le taux de natalité
vous devriez vous en féliciter plutôt
que de crier haro sur leurs droits
c'est pourtant bien dans la stratégie de
lisbonne qu'il ait dit que tout doit
être fait pour favoriser le travail des
femmes
je conclurai en faisant écho au débat
sur les retraites car l'une des clés
pour préserver notre modèle par
répartition et bien sûr la nécessité
d'avoir un taux de natalité élevé mais
pas seulement
il s'agit également de revoir la place
de la femme dans le monde du travail et
permettre qu'elles accèdent à un emploi
stable à temps plein si elle le souhaite
et rémunérés à la hauteur de la
rémunération des hommes c'est ainsi que
l'on combattra des inégalités de
pensions des retraites
je vous remercie
si monsieur collègues m'ont ensuite de
discussion générale la parole et à
gisèle printz pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans le droit fil
des initiatives récentes de l'union
européenne visant à garantir les droits
des femmes et améliorer leur situation
en effet en 2008 dans le cadre de la
conciliation entre la vie
professionnelle et la vie familiale
la commission européenne avait proposé
de modifier la directive 92 85 c e
enfin de porter la durée minimale du
congé de maternité à 18 semaines et de
rendre obligatoire un arrêt dont 1 6
semaines après l'accouchement
cette proposition contenait d'autres
avancées importantes comme le principe
de l'interdiction de licenciement des
femmes enceintes
tout comme le droit de bénéficier de
l'ensemble des avantages accordés à
leurs collègues pendant leur absence ou
encore la possibilité de demander une
modification des horaires et rythmes de
travail
enfin la commission européenne acté le
principe du maintien du salaire complet
perçu avant le congé maternité
en octobre 2010 le parlement européen
est allé plus loin en adoptant une loi
instaurant à congé maternité de 20
semaines minimum rémunéré à 100% du
salaire suivant ainsi les
recommandations de l'oit et il s'agit
aujourd'hui d'allonger la durée du congé
de maternité en france qui avec ses
semaines se situent dans la moyenne
basse en europe
rappelons par exemple qu'il est de 26
semaines en italie de 28 semaines au
danemark
cette proposition de loi vise donc à
adapter notre législation à l'évolution
du droit européen
elle propose d'en augmenter la durée de
16 à 20 semaines
cela répond à une attente des femmes qui
aiment rester plus longtemps auprès de
leur bébé
mais c'est aussi une question de santé
publique en période prénatale le congé
maternité est une nécessité
aux applications du travail sur la santé
les trajets en voiture les transports en
commun pour se rendre sur son lieu de
travail en période postnatale les maires
sont fatigués et plus encore si elles
sont si elles ont subi une césarienne
l'accouchement nécessite une période de
récupération suffisamment longue le
rejet de principe de cette mesure au
motif qu'elles créent de nouvelles
dépenses publiques et de nouvelles
charges pour les entreprises est selon
nous inacceptable la maternité ne peut
pas être considérée comme un fardeau
pesant sur les systèmes de sécurité
sociale alors qu'il s'agit de la santé
des femmes et du renouvellement des
générations
c'est un investissement pour l'avenir un
autre argument entendu en commission des
affaires sociales selon lequel les
femmes seraient plus difficilement
employables est tout aussi recevable une
enquête de 2006 sur l'allongement du
congé maternité en france prouve qu'on
pratique la majorité des femmes a
recours ou congé pathologique aux congés
payés aux congés sans solde pour
prolonger le congé maternité
seulement 12% des femmes ne s'arrête que
cette semaine
cela confirme qu'elles ont réellement
besoin d'un congé plus long et que les
coûts de ces arrêts pour les entreprises
l'état et les familles existent déjà
arrêtons d'être hypocrite de plus cette
proposition de loi oblige l'employeur à
évoquer l'adaptation des conditions et
horaires de travail avec l'intéressé à
son retour du congé de maternité elle
propose aussi le maintien intégral du
salaire car il n'existe aujourd'hui
aucune obligation légale à son maintien
il dépend des accords passés dans le
cadre des conventions collectives la
situation des femmes qui exercent des
professions non salariées chefs
d'entreprise artisans conjoints
collaborateurs est également prise en
compte afin de leur permettre de mener à
bien la maternité
la proposition prévoit pour elle le
bénéfice d'un congé rémunéré
qui prenne en compte leurs besoins de
remplacement au sein de l'entreprise
ce n'est que justice envers ces femmes
qui pourront vivre pleinement cet
ailleurs sans éprouver de culpabilité
enfin cette proposition de loi aborde la
prend et social celui de la présence du
père à la naissance de l'enfant
le grand huit de paternité créé en 2001
par ségolène royal alors ministre de la
famille a été un pas décisif en ce sens
il développe le sentiment de maternité
et l'implication du père dans le partage
des tâches
car nous le savons les responsabilités
familiales et le travail domestique non
partagé handicap les femmes et génère
des inégalités sur le marché du travail
malheureusement seulement deux tiers des
pères prennent leurs congés de paternité
on peut y voir la persistance de
stéréotypes dans la définition des rôles
parentaux
la proposition de loi vise donc à mieux
appliquer le père par un congé de
paternité de 14 jours consécutifs
rebaptisé congé d'accueil de l'enfant
pourra bénéficier
la personne devra vivre maritalement
avec la mère quel que soit son statut
juridique marie pacs est au plus bas
cet ex contribuer à l'évolution de notre
législation pour l'adapter aux réalités
actuelles des familles c'est un premier
pas en attendant une politique plus
globale et plus volontariste sur le
congé parental d'éducation
il est très peu répandu chez les hommes
à cause de la baisse de rémunération
qu'ils appliquent aujourd'hui le père
n'est plus seulement le symbole de
l'autorité au sein de la famille il est
désormais présent au même titre que la
mère pour gérer tous les aspects du
quotidien beaucoup de ce que l'on
qualifie de nouveaux pères
s'investissent dans les soins apportés
aux enfants dès les premiers jours il
faut les encourager et aller plus loin
la france pourrait proposer à tous les
couples à dispositif s'assurant du
modèle suédois ou le congé parental de
16 mois et mieux rémunéré est partagé
entre les deux parents afin d'encourager
partage de l'éducation des enfants c'est
essentiel pour favoriser l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes
mais c'est surtout bénéfique pour
l'épanouissement de l'enfant
il faut aussi développer les modes de
garde l'absence de structures d'accueil
pour les enfants m'ont scolarisés est
réelle dans notre pays et il reste
encore beaucoup à faire mais dans
l'immédiat
nous vous proposons d'adopter cette
proposition de loi
elle représente un progrès pour la santé
des femmes et constitue un premier pas
vers une politique familiale que
ambitieuse aujourd'hui nous affichons un
taux de fécondité élevée nous en sommes
fiers
car les enfants sont une richesse pour
notre pays il faut témoigner de la
considération et de l'estimé aux futurs
maîtres qui parviennent à concilier vie
familiale et vie professionnelle
si l'on veut que les femmes continuent à
être des mères encourage les en
améliorant leurs conditions de vie je
voterai dans cette proposition de loi
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
la discussion générale la parole est à
ronan kerdraon pour le groupe socialiste
dernier orateur inscrit
j pas d'anomalie billes je précise il en
fallait un monsieur le président madame
la ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteure mes chers collègues nous
sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour évoquer
la modernisation d'un des éléments clés
de notre politique familiale à savoir le
congé de maternité et je suis
particulièrement heureux en tant
qu'homme de m'exprimer dans cet
hémicycle
personne n'est parfait sur une question
qui touche quant aux évolutions de notre
société qu'à la place que nous
souhaitons donner à la femme dans celle
ci
je veux avant tout saluer l'initiative
de notre rapporteur claire-lise campion
et les avancées que permet sa
proposition de loi
son contenu est tout à la fois moderne
et utile en cela qu'ils répondent aux
préoccupations de beaucoup de jeunes
couples
le texte dont nous débattons aujourd'hui
montre aussi combien le chemin reste
long pour aboutir à une égalité réelle
entre les hommes et les femmes la
plupart des orateurs avant moi l'ont
signalé les termes de notre débat
s'inscrivent dans le cadre d'une
harmonisation par le haut des
législations européennes
c'est suffisamment rare pour le
souligner en effet les directives
européennes sont souvent vécues à tort
ou à raison comme un recul pour notre
modèle français
aussi je me réjouis pleinement de
l'adoption le 23 février 2010 par le
parlement européen d'un rapport invitant
les pays membres à instituer un congé de
maternité de 20 semaines
de même que je me réjouis de l'adoption
le 8 mars 2010 de la directive sur le
congé parental qui porte ce dernier de
trois à quatre mois et qui établit le
principe d'un mois non transférable
entre parents ainsi qu'une négociation
obligatoire avec l'employeur sur
l'aménagement d'un horaire de travail au
retour du congé parental
la présente loi s'inscrit dans la lignée
de ces initiatives européennes
alors je voudrais d'emblée écarté l'un
des arguments avancés contre notre
proposition à savoir bien évidemment son
coût et son financement
selon les projections du ministère de la
santé du ministère du travail
l'allongement lors se reprendre et
l'exemple de 18 semaines qui a été
évoqué tout à l'heure l'allongement à 18
semaines de la durée du congé de
maternité coûterait entre 250 et 350
millions d'euros
l'allongement conjointe du côlon g de
maternité et du congé de paternité
coûterait environ 550 millions d'euros
petite comparaison rapide je vous
rappellerai que la baisse de la tva dans
la restauration a pour sa part conduit à
3 milliards de dépenses fiscales pour le
résultat que nous connaissons tous la
question du financement relève donc d'un
choix politique fort et assumer car il
est des dépenses qui sont des
investissements pour l'avenir
c'est le cas de notre proposition de loi
certes nous avons une politique
familiale volontariste
madame la ministre a rappelé tout à
l'heure notre pays consacrent une part
non négligeable de son pib à cette
politique familiale ce qui d'ailleurs
place notre pays en troisième position
au sein des pays de l'osce odhir nous
disposons également de l'un des
meilleurs taux de fécondité avec 2,02
enfants par femme
cependant depuis plusieurs années les
attentes et les modes de vie de nos
concitoyens évolué
la conciliation des vies familiale et
professionnelle est au coeur de leurs
préoccupations
toutes les enquêtes le montrent en
particulier celle de la drees sur le
congé de maternité
lequel est jugé insuffisant par les
maires 84% soit très s'arrêter plus
longtemps et les femmes à juste titre
souhaite avoir des enfants sans renoncer
à leur carrière professionnelle
or un chiffre doit nous interpeller tous
entre 25 et 49 ans âge où l'activité
professionnelle est la plus fréquente
une femme sur cinq n'est pas active en
outre ce sont celles qui sont le moins
qualifiés et qui dispose des ressources
les plus faibles qui sont le plus
souvent écartés du marché du travail
remarquons également que pour de
multiples raisons
l'âge de la maternité ne cesse de
reculer les femmes devenant désormais
mère pour la première fois après l'âge
de 30 ans nous proposons ainsi avec
l'article 1
l'allongement de la durée légale du
congé de maternité à 20 semaines au lieu
des 16 existantes
d'ailleurs la très grande majorité des
femmes ça a été rappelé également
s'arrête plus longtemps que les 16
semaines légales soit qu'elles se soient
vu reconnaître une grossesse
pathologique soit qu'elles aient pris
des congés supplémentaires après la
naissance de l'enfant
aussi il me paraît tout à fait judicieux
de mettre notre législation en
adéquation avec les aspirations des
couples et les besoins de l'enfant
l'allongement de la durée du congé de
maternité présente également l'avantagé
de promouvoir une prolongation de
l'allaitement maternel en facilitant son
installation je vais vous donner
quelques précisions pour bien installer
un allaitement durant les premières
semaines il faut au moins six semaines
or c'est précisément à cette période que
la mer commence à penser à la reprise de
son activité professionnelle et envisage
un sevrage en vue de sa reprise
d'activité à la 10e semaine
c'est pourquoi l'association française
de pid de pédiatrie ambulatoire soutien
l'allongement du congé de maternité
alors que la crise économique frappe
toutes les catégories de français
il est difficile d'admettre aujourd'hui
encore des jeunes mères de famille
puisse être pénalisés financièrement
dans le cadre d'un congé de maternité
quand leurs employeurs ne sont pas
engagés contractuellement à maintenir
leurs salaires c'est pour cela que
l'article 4 garantit le maintien de
l'intégralité du salaire pendant le
congé de maternité trop d'inégalités
subsistent qu'il est temps d'introduire
des mesures d'égalité pour toutes les
mères qu'elles soient salariés ou non
car en france le congé de maternité ne
va pas forcément de soi et je veux comme
ma collègue annie david relayé ici
l'appel du collectif des matermittentes
qui dénoncent l'inégalité de traitement
dont sont victimes les intermittentes
pour avoir accès aux indemnités de congé
de maternité la cpam de monde aux femmes
enceintes de réunir les mêmes conditions
que celles en cdi
cette lutte contre l'injustice de statut
entre les catégories de salariés entre
salariés et non salariés doit être prise
en compte
c'est le sens même de l'article 5 de
cette proposition de loi
l'article 6 du texte propose la création
d'un congé d'accueil de l'enfant de deux
semaines permettant aux pères ou
conjoint voilà personne vivant
maritalement ou ayant conclu un pacte
avec la mère d'être présent auprès de la
mère et de l'enfant la législation doit
donc évoluer et ne plus faire référence
à un congé de paternité mais bien à un
congé d'accueil de l'enfant
ouvert à toutes les familles dans leur
diversité enfin nous ne pouvons pas
déconnecter notre débat ce jour de la
question de l'offre d'accueil pour la
petite enfance à quoi servirait-il de
favoriser la reprise du travail
d'évoquer une meilleure conciliation
entre vie familiale et vie
professionnelle
si aucune politique d'accueil ambitieuse
de la petite enfance n'est menée la
création d'un service public de la
petite enfance et est je le rappelle une
promesse du candidat sarkozy à
l'élection présidentielle de 2007
une de plus me direz vous or disons le
nous sommes très loin des 400 mille
places en crèche promise lors de cette
campagne nous sommes loin des 200 milles
promise pour 2012 et je vous rappelle
que nous sommes en 2011
le débat que nous avons ici la semaine
dernière sur la petite enfance a
clairement mis en évidence ce déficit
mes chers collègues ce texte nous permet
de faire progresser les droits des
femmes il améliore la protection de la
santé des femmes fait avancer le droit à
l'égalité et permet un meilleur
équilibre au sein de la famille entre
les parents chacun se dit favorable à
l'égalité entre hommes et femmes en tous
domaines professionnels salariale et
familiale ce texte par conséquent est le
bienvenu pourquoi remettre à demain ce
que l'on peut faire aujourd'hui c'est
donc avec enthousiasme conviction et
détermination que je le voterai que je
vous appelle à voter car comme l'a si
bien chanté jean ferrat la femme est
l'avenir de l'homme
je vous remercie
bien cette façon vous êtes d'accord sur
ces références littéraires et sur le
chanteur et sur le poète madame la
ministre monsieur le président je
voulais évidemment remercié les
sénatrices et les sénateurs qui sont
intervenus dans cet important débat pour
la qualité de leurs interventions qui
était bien documenté et qui évidemment
ont tant que faire se peut abandonner la
polémique merci encore à kerlys campion
pour avoir lancé ce débat je voudrais
apporter quelques précisions
il a beaucoup été question exemples
européens et en particulier a dit david
et gisèle printz mais justement les
exemples européens nous montre la
difficulté du dossier
par exemple en vente la slovaquie avec
ses 28 semaines de congé maternité à
qu'on est heureux en slovaquie on oublie
de dire que la rémunération est à 55 %
la salaire plafonné extrêmement bas
alors effectivement 28 semaines avec 55%
à salaire plafonné à un niveau très très
très peu élevé on voit bien que ça
suscite quand même un certain nombre
d'interrogations que là encore
comparaison n'est pas raison
donc il faut évoquer la durée de la du
congé mais également son indemnisation
c'est très important
également il faut relever que les
comparaisons doivent introduire la
notion de rands naissance qui n'a jamais
été abordé au cours de la discussion par
exemple en france pour la troisième
naissance de congé est porté à vingt six
semaines à aucun moment le débat n'a
introduit cet élément qui est un nouvel
élément élément de comparaison à nouvel
élément de comparaison par rapport à la
france
quid du congé pathologique je rappelle
que
congé pathologique de deux semaines et
prient pas 70% des femmes on peut penser
que 70% des femmes n'ont pas une
grossesse pathologique
c'est donc qu'en fait pour 70% des
femmes d'ores et déjà le congé de
maternité à 18 semaines
on en a parlé à aucun moment du débat on
voit des pays également qu'ils
considèrent que l'allongement du congé
de maternité ou un congé de maternité
extrêmement long et vécu pour certains
comme une politique délibérée
d'éloignement des femmes du marché du
travail c'est parfaitement clair c'est
même parfois revendiqué publiquement par
un certain nombre de pays et par un
certain nombre de partis politiques qui
militent pour le retour des femmes à la
maison je vous renvoie et c'est fort
intéressant à certains débats du conseil
européen du parlement européen excusez
moi certains débats du parlement
européen au moment où on a discuté de
l'allongement du congé de maternité je
prendrai l'exemple de la bulgarie par
exemple on a un magnifique congé de
maternité à 58 même où s'est revendiqué
comme une mesure d'éloignement des
femmes du congé du du monde du travail
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance pour
la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr à suivre l'émission
politique de la rédaction de public
sénat preuve par trois avec ce soir
comme invité catherine tasca
vice-présidente socialiste du sénat très
belle soirée à tous